what here this video playing Zack Martin
from Turkey and let's see how maybe I
can play this for a change the Kings
Indian attack or the Catalan all the
rate Reggie okay let's let's do the
Catalan idea 3g 3sm very flexible
opening the a Bishop g5 this is probably
the safest move available them not only
leading to to end game type of positions
where black can equalize with precise
play but it soon needs to be done it
still needs to prove something so what
I'm trying to say it's not like it's an
equality with with NE muth see five
years the main move this is also
possible
there are many ways that are not many is
a bit a bit much but there are some ways
that I can play and be close to equality
but you need to play one of them be sure
before now is played or c5 it's about
possible
20 form here maybe yeah that's could be
an idea double attacking on c5 and here
and now we are the queen is some
interesting options can go to worm a 7
for instance yeah let's do that try to
attack the a6 pawn and maybe irritate am
a bit this is 95 if you have it which
can be quite annoying attacking the rook
and detecting the bishop
hmm yeah not quite sure what you should
do not not that that he's lost or
anything but um it's not easy to play
also might be 92 lamb probably against
92 we can take ji tun but ok let's see
what is what is playing are there are
many many moves ok does this is some
preventing 92 quite convincingly night
855 the 95 Bishop g2 94 others rooks is
7
okay so route c7 and this is a an idea
in the position anyway ok so it will
probably play this in any case so maybe
just keep it keep things as they are
enroute c7 I drop back to deform now
Queen f5 is probably a good defensive
move
so Roxy's 7 always hmm
maybe still go down it shouldn't be it
it's not badly placed here only five
yeah 25 was a good a good good defensive
moves that you played there I guess
against Queen a seven black gum should
should have equalised here mhm
now it's attacking you too I'm not sure
if I want to play your form yeah not
sure about this but I need to make sure
that I'm not falling totally behind on
the clock rook see one yeah this a to
hanging
yeah but I want to I don't want to play
a lame move here there is always ideas
with Luke c7 for example Roxy said
nobody's got queen bee one yeah while
still very quickly played yeah I hope
that I have some some decent
compensation here maybe maybe that's not
the case but check here just Queen f2 is
Queen trait is not term check the big
problem with the night only five rook on
g7 this should be compensation really
check
preventing the roof from entering 994
maybe maybe has that okay too
yeah preventing I am protecting be to
preparing be 495 is night does not have
any any great route before and 95 coming
my baby still night time back here I'm
threatening and made Juke f7 decimate
threat Oh check checkmate oh yeah okay
witness a bit silly but i think i had to
compensation you for the pawn starting
starting here um i don't think i should
play a passive move here like a three or
something and I'm not I'm not totally
sure but oh he had rookie to this this I
don't I didn't see really attacking him
and I cannot player three the computer
gives funny enough gives a three rook
takes Queen c5 as compensation now very
tough to to play for for human after
this I think I i have i have a decent
compensation check check yeah yeah
auntie em okay the computer is already
giving me a big advantage yeah I
suspected that but I wasn't I wasn't
totally sure he a rook c8 and taking on
f7 was already possible yeah yeah of
course I had seen this but what I what I
hadn't seen is this that I'm threatening
a threatening directly here I thought
you can play here but check this is
check this is very very precarious the
king and I'm can I can go back now okay
yeah this this was was better this is
keeping an edge but it's not as
convincing but here he runs right into
95 ya hear what is winning and really
have no move for 90 f6 is also
blundering the the night so um tricky
yeah he played a good game here with
quick Queen a5 was a good defense
against this idea probably a rook see
one hears is better anyway now okay
thanks for watching